[Music]
Magnus you ready for this uh I've never
done this before so I wouldn't know
so when did you understand that this was
a draw
when did I understand it was a draw
I understood it immediately
aliens come to Earth they challenge you
to a game of chess you have to save
Humanity what opening do you play
in such a case I'd probably play an
opening like one night at three or or
the English or some opening that like
that try to to outsmart them eventually
uh besides I mean if I make a couple of
quiet moves at the start I will probably
be able to tell whether the aliens are
any good at chess or or not
I don't know if you were following the
action but Sabi and Wesley have been
knocked out did you follow the matches
there yeah it's just me against the kids
now